やあみんなデルガンここにいるので、今日は
ラファエル・ヤキと一緒に参加し
ます。彼はおそらくサイバーパンクのエッジランナーでの彼の仕事であなたの多くに最もよく知られています.Netflix
の番組
とウィッチャーローニンでも
非常に長い話を短くします.私は最近、
サイバーパンクのエッジランナーを見ました.
すぐに私のお気に入りのアニメ
に
なりました すごく気に入りました 言葉では言い尽くせないくらい大好きになりました ラファエルが別府に来ることを知ったとき 彼に連絡したところ彼は
快く会うことに同意してくれました
このビデオでは、彼の頭脳を取り上げたいと思います。
願わくば
、彼の創造的なプロセスと彼
が過去に行ったすべての仕事についてもっと学びたいと
思います。それでは、これ以上前置きはせずに、簡単な自己紹介をしていただけませ
んか。
dogen は私の名前は Rafael Yaki と言っていました。
ええと、私
は 10 年以上前にビデオ ゲーム業界で働き始めました。
ええと、10
年間の大半は、ウィッチャーとサイバーパンク 20 の背後にある会社である CD project red にいました。
77.私はビジネスパーソンとしてスタートし、
その後、よりプロデューサー的なものに移行しました.
数
年前、私はビデオゲームにあるすべてのものを担当して
いましたが、一種
の創造的でした.
ウィッチャー 3 のミニゲームを考えついた 2 人のうち、私
は IPS 用のボードゲームの束に取り組み、
その後
、
Kickstarter で、what if ストーリーである what you're Ronin で作家デビューを果たしました。 ジェラルド
がヨーロッパの中世ファンタジーではなく、日本で浪人だった
としたらどうでしょう? 5年以上のバックグラウンドで、
私は
サイバーパンケットランナーズに5年以上取り組んで、そのショーを
大丈夫
にしました.
このビデオを録画する直前に考えたことすべて Ronin を読んで
、それ自体がすごいと思った
もちろん、あなたは日本に住んでいたか住んでいなかった
が、大学で日本語を勉強
していた
ええと、12歳の時
初めて
日本で作られたものを意識的に見て、
それがそれだと知っていたので
、その瞬間、私にとって
深い何かが開かれたように感じ
ました。
できる限りそれに近づきたいというのは魅力的で
、それから
故郷での最初のアニメコンベンションに行きまし
た.200人か
何かだったので、地元のクラブのようなものに参加しました.
日本の文化とフンガンのアニメ
に熱中し、そのクラブの何人かは
ワルシャワ大学に行って
日本語の文献学を学びました。
彼らはすでに私のクラブの先輩でした。
私は計画を立て
、両親には行かないように話しました。
高校で良い成績を取るためには、
ワーズ大学の日本語学に専念するつもりです。
そこに行くのが私の夢でしたし、
その話はとても面白いので、私はそれに本当に集中しました。 自分の
b 私が入学しようとした年だったので、それは私の
国全体で最も人気のあるカリキュラム
でした.1つのスペースに50人だったのは興味深いこと
でした。 あなたは
満点200対200を持っていなければなり
ませんでした入試のようにええええまあ高校の試験の終わりのようなものではありません
大丈夫これ
は州のように正しく座っていて、ポーランドや
何か違うものですが基本的に
同じです コンセプトです
が、200点満点中190点だったので、入ることができませんでした。
それでもかなり高いです
。最善を尽くしましたが、満点は取れませんでし
たが、とても人気があったので
、学部長はさらに20のスポットを開きました。
しかし、100リストに入っていた
人は
誰でも
、次の日に最初にサインインした人は誰でも
リストに
サインインするというメールを送信
しました。 大学の根拠を確認するためだけ
に いい感じに入ることができたし、
それはあなたがプレッシャーの
忍耐力のことを知っていて
、運のことを知っているかもしれませんが、それはそのように開かれ
、ええ、私は
学士号の最初の3年間を過ごし、
それから私は行きました 修士号を取得するために、
実際には修了していませんでし
た 私は 5 年生でしたが、すでに
かなり安定した仕事に就いて
いて、翻訳者に
なることも、日本語学校に行くこともないとわかっていました。
私にとってその未来を追求する工場会社で
あり、それは常に
私にとって情熱的なことのようでし
た。当時は本当に良い仕事を得たので
、仕事と大学を同時に行うことはできないようだっ
たので、中退しました。 ええと、5年後に
修士
号を取得できませんでした 学士号を取得しました
が、入学前に面接があり、取得
したい場合はポップカルチャーについて言及することはできないという規則がありました。
それ
はアニメだから仕方
ない 事はそれであり、
後で私が実際に理解したのは
、もしそれがあなたが取りつかれていない場合
、そしてそれがあなたの動機であった場合、
あなたはそこに行ったのでアニメに近づくと思ったのですが
、私たちのようなケースではありませんでした. 茶道を学びました
私たちは日本の歴史を始め
ました 食文化のようなすべての
言語 あなたが知っているすべての言語
毎週たくさんの漢字を知っています
そしてそれはあなたの唯一の動機がアニメだったとしたら、
それらすべての人々が中退したのは
私だけでした
私はその興味があったからです
日本はすべてそうです、そうです、マンガを知っています。
つまり、私
が興味を持っていたのは
マンガだけで
はありませんでした。 もちろん、
私はアニメの大ファンだったので、私たちはその意味で似ていたと思います
が、
私はアニメ
という意味でのオタクではありませんでした。アニメは私の人生
でし
た。
私は
禅仏教とアニメに夢中だったので、
それからマーシャル全体
を通して、高校全体で
フリースタイル武道のアクロバットのようなトリックをしました。
空手も好きなので、
私が非常に興味を持っていた文化の複数の部分は、
その点で非常に似てい
ます.ええと、あなたはアニメについて話すことができませんでしたが
、私があなたに尋ねたい質問の1つは、
いくつかは何ですか.
インスピレーション
、芸術作品
、アニメ、映画
、
ウィッチャー、
ローニン、サイバーパンクなど
、たくさんありますが、私は知りません。 十分な時間があることはわかっていますが
、
いくつかのメディアで
自分の核心を動かされたと思います。
私の人生を本当に変えたのは新
世紀エヴァンゲリオンで、ファイルで見ました。
共産主義時代の後のポーランドでは
、そのようなものの合法的なコピーを入手できなかった
ので、明らかに海賊版を作成する必要があったため、インターネット経由でダウンロードしまし
たが、それは16メガバイトの
ファイルで、ほとんど何も見ることができません
でした。  320対240
くらいの比率だったけど観て
【音楽】
何か変わった気
がした よく
分からなかったけど今までになかった感覚
があった そうじゃない棚のように開いた 私
はそれが存在することさえ知りませんでした、
そしてその時点から、
それは本当に私に何かを叫んでいた創造主の声だと思い
ました。それは非常に
ユニークな経験でした。なぜなら
、家族の絆のようなものの外では、おそらく親しい友人と一緒に
、イエスのような感情を誰も伝えなかったからです
大丈夫ですええと、
私にとってエヴァンゲリオンは今日までまだとても
重要な
メディアであり、実際には最後の
映画だと思います 最近出てきたニュース ええ、
私は明らかに最後に泣いていまし
たが、私はそうでした 李 ke oh hidakiano は
今は元気で、エヴァンゲリオンでの彼の作品
は彼のうつ病の状態のように見えるので、彼は彼です
が、この映画の後、彼は
幸せで面白い
です.  20年間、
あなたは自分が誰で、何を表現したいのかというジェットコースターを経験しましたが
、今は幸せで、
彼がちょうどそこに行っ
て全世界に彼のすべてを示したように、彼のすべての感情的な人生
はそれがコアの内側にあります
それを見るのはとても興味深いものでしたが、
最後に私はとても幸せでした.彼は今幸せでした.
ええ、とてもカタルシスの瞬間です.
ええ
、これは私がずっと尋ねたかった質問への完璧な移行のようなものだと思います.
多くの人が非常に長い間、
私はあなたがおそらく
この質問に答えるのに最も適した人物だと思い
ます.
st オリテリングと
フリルはなく、そこにある必要のないものは何
もありません.
この前に、私たちは
アリストテレスの詩学について非常に簡単に話し始めました。
基本的には最悪のタイプです。
なぜなら、タイムライン全体に存在
する闘争を取り込もうとするとエピソード的になる闘争を取ることに
なりますが、フィラーコンテンツを追加する
と、闘争が希薄になり、実際
にはキャラクターに関係しなくなります。
私たちが彼らと一緒に闘争を正しく行っているのと同じくらい、それが
私がいつも
考えていたことであり、それが私がエッジランナーについてとても愛していた
ことです。とても
集中し
ていて、含めることができないものは何もありませ
ん ストーリーであり、それは
エピソードに分割されたという意味ですが、それは
正確に1つの統合されたストーリー
であり、私がcであなたに言ったことの1つではないことは確かです.
以前は
、カウボーイビバップよりも優れていると思いました.それ
をキャンセルしようとする人がいるかもしれません
が、その理由の1つは、
私がカウボーイビバップを絶対に愛し
ているからです.もちろん傑作です
が
、唯一の批評です. カウボーイビバップの特徴
は
、彼らが何かをし
て戻ってくるという大規模なストーリーとは関係のないエピソードがいくつかあるように感じたということです。その意味で
、シリーズが少し持っていた店のように感じました
ダウンタイムの
繰り返しで、エッジランナーはまったくそのように感じませんでした。
私はずっと
席の端にいました。
次のエピソードは完璧です。次のエピソード
は完璧です
アリストテレスが同じ段落で書いた別のこと
は
、多かれ少なかれ完全なシリーズ
またはこれらのキャラクターを持つ物語を取り上げると、  s、そして
あなたはそれを伸ばそうとします.それを伸ばそうとすると、
最終的に
それを希釈することに反対します.
もちろん、新生エヴァンゲリオンで
は最初のシーズンがあり、その後に
映画のようなカップルが
ありました.ええ、それからいくつかの映画がありました.
その後のようなもので、
最近出てきた映画が
適切なアリのようなものであると考えられている理由は、
ええ、少なくとも、
作成者がずっと望んでいたが、
到達できなかった終わりであると私は信じています。  20年、彼は
ついに部門の終わりに到達しましたはいはい、
これは私の質問のようなものです
.2426エピソードシリーズを信じる最初のオリジナル
を見
ました.
物事がちょっとおかしくなる最後のいくつ
かのエピソードまでは、彼らが望んでいたようにそれを作るための予算がなかったというのは私の理解だと思います.
確かにそうだと思います
が、トリガーには実際に大多数の婦人科の人々がいるので、そこにいた人々に尋ねることができます
が、
ほとんどが
そうだったと思います。
当時の彼は私が思うに彼
がそれについて話していたので、彼
は彼を上手に描いたマンガがあり、彼は彼の人生とある種の闘争を描いていて、彼は
自分はただの難破船だと言っていた
ので、大丈夫でした。 そして、それは作品に表れていると思います。
なぜなら、最後に
は、間違った選択が行われるという希望はないように見えるからです。
すべてがめちゃくちゃになり、
とても憂鬱
です。
その時点でのクリエイターであり、それが聴衆に伝わると思います
わかりました 非常に興味深いです
私はそれについてあまり考えていませんでした
シリーズだけにもっと集中しようとしているので、そうです
、その意味で、エッジ
ランナーが私にとって特別なものになったのは、
すべてのピースが適切な場所にあるように感じたから
です。
あなたはもともと CD プロジェクト Red 内で複数の作業を行っていましたが
、最初の大きなクリエイティブな
Endeavor は Witcher Ronin
でした。これは私が本当にクリエイティブな所有権を持ってい
たものです。ある意味
で、キャロルを最初から私のアイデアでし
た。
ポータルが開かれ、
中世のキャラクターが日本に行くの
ではなく
、独自の特徴を持つキャラクターが
ファンタジーの日本ではなくファンタジーの日本で生まれたとしたらどうなるかという意味での別の設定とシナリオ。
中世ヨーロッパの設定は正しく、
その時点から、私はそのジャンプをするのが非常に簡単
でした フロリダ 一般的な文化のように並んでい
ます はい、たとえば、カッパは、
ああ、彼らはこのように面白いです、ええ、
あなたが知っ
ているように、彼らはいたずら好きで、彼らには独自の
特別な癖
がありました。  「
彼は
モンスターハンターであり、モンスターと彼の
特別なことは
、彼がいつも行っている調査の一部であることを知っているようです.
日本語でそれはうまくいくと思いました.
私たちは
日本に来ます 日本人はいつも
彼は浪人だと私に言います 彼は
キャラクターのように村から村へ行きます
ええ仕事はありません ええ小さなコインのために仕事をし
ます
日本人の典型的な
キャラクターやその
ようなキャラクターはそれが当てはまると感じたので
、ジャンプは簡単だろうと
思った 読者のためだったらいいのに
そういう意味で
楽しかったらいいのに
これの直前に、私はそれが大好きでした
今では自然に複数のアートスタイルがあり
ますこれはあなた
が最初から念頭に置いていたものでしたか、それとも
あなたがここでそれを作成していたときにそのアイデアを持って
い
ましたかプロデューサーは私のようなキックのようなものでした.
ある意味で、ハタヤ
は漫画本のメインアークのアーティストです
はい
、彼女は時間枠内で非常に多くのアートしか制作できず、
より多くのアーティストが関与する
ことで制作の観点からそれが可能になり
ました 制作の観点から
実際に 彼女はより大きな漫画本を持っていて、当然の
ことながら
、これのアートを行うのに1年以上かかったので
、日本の
クリエイターがたくさんいると思ったので
、一緒に何かをしたいと思った.
この世界のさまざまな側面を紹介
しますが、それが何であるかという IP のコア コンセプト
については、私も私も
アーティストと一緒に仕事をするのが
大好きです。
ええと、スクリーン ジーザス クライスト 名前を忘れました
悲鳴を上げる スクリーン 脚本 はい
、脚本と同じように、通常、現在
のコミックでは、特にアメリカン
コミックでは、多くの
監督と執筆が同時に行われている
ため、作家は
執筆中に監督になります。 彼はまた、スクリプト
がどのように行われるかについてアーティストに指示します。
彼らが大丈夫と言うという意味で興味深い
ので、ページの最初のパネルの4つの
パネルゲラルトは正しく見えます。
そして、彼は
基本的にその時点で映画監督です
はい、もはや脚本家ではありません 彼は
そうです 彼は監督です はい 私は
そのように書きません 私は子供たちが正直になるのが好きではありません
アーティストが解釈する余地はほとんどないと感じているからです ええ、そうです。
ですから、イラン語はすべて、
ご存じのとおりの方法で書かれています。
ゲラルトが部屋に入るような脚本があります。
これとこれとこれ
とこれが会話で、これが去ります。
アーティストのための多くの解釈があるので、
私はさまざまなアーティストと仕事をするのが大好きです。
なぜなら、彼らは状況を自分で解釈できるからです。
はい、
そうではない可能性が高いです。彼らの創造性に喜んでいるでしょう。
質問
はありますか?もちろん、
あなたのインスピレーションについて少し前に話しました
が、主なものは
ええと
エヴァンゲリオンです
が、執筆に関して、執筆
中に自分で試して持っ
ているルールやガイドラインはありますか? または、ルーティンのようなものはありますか、または
あなたがよく従うようなものはあります
か。私はここの私の先生にとても似ていると思います。
彼はまた、エッジランナーの脚本を書きました。ええ
、彼はローニンのやり方を教えてくれました。
15 年間コミック本の作成者であり、
彼はこれより前にテレビで長年働いていました。
もちろん、私にはビデオゲームの優れた作家がたくさんいました
が、ビデオゲームの執筆
は非常に異なってい
ます。 ビーストをレンタル
するのは、コミックやアニメや映画で行う直線的なストーリーテリングと同じように、
まったく
異なるものなので
、これについてバルトスと一緒に仕事をしている
バルトスから知っていることを学びました。 最初の
質問は劇的な質問です はい、
もし
あなたの人生で何か重要なことがあれ
ば、あなたを満たすような質問が
あり、それを探求する必要があります
その劇的な質問を念頭に置いて、あなたが望むことをしようとする
ストーリーと
プロットラインに違いがある場合、正しいストーリーは
、家族が死亡し、プロットライン
が誰かが葬式に行く場合にどうなるかです。彼ら
は街に行き、彼らはこの
冒険をします。障害物
構造と、おそらくヒーローの旅が
何であれ それはそうなるでしょうが、それ
は問題ではありませんそれは実体がありませんそれは
ただキャラクターに起こっていることです
はいそしてその劇的な質問は
これと並行して物語が良いものになります
私
はアーロン・ソーキンがマスタークラスを受講したとあなたが
言ったのはおかしいと私は同意し
ます 苦労
ではなく、あなたが持っているロードトリップのよう
な物語
を書くことになるだけです. ストーリーは、
誰かが家族と疎遠になっていて
、クリスマスに集まりたいと思っています
が、これは
コメディかもしれませ
ん これは大丈夫かもしれませ
ん コメディかもしれません ドラマかもしれませ
ん
その劇的な質問を探求しようとしているので、その劇的な質問
に基づいて障害物が出現する
ので、私にとっては、たとえばエッジランナーの場合は
はい そして、
私たちが開発している間、彼はドラマチックな質問にたどり着きました。
それは
ショーで見られる最後の質問です。あなたは
去ることができますか、他の誰かの夢を生きることができますか
、
そして夢の部分はエッジランナーのすべての部分に強制さ​​れました
それを
より強くするために、
10話20分程度の比較的小さな部分が
絶対にいくらかの力を持つことができますが
、それがなければ、あなたが300話のアニメ
を撮影したことを知っているように、他のことを考えるのと同じです。
この種のものです
が、おそらく劇的な質問は
それぞれのように変化
する必要があり、追求
する必要があり、観客がまだあなたと一緒にいることを確認する必要があり
ます。
メディア
20年以上一緒にいるように大好きで、
私が
実際に終わらせることを非常に恐れています。
毎週のワンピースがなければ
私の人生に何が起こるかわかりません
が、
私が言おうとしていたのは、彼がシリーズ
のこの右の過程で劇的な質問を変え
、彼
はさまざまな質問を探求しているということです. そして彼はあなた
が1つのピースをさまざまな
タイプのものに切り分けて取り出すことができ、
おそらくいくつかの文脈が失われるかもしれませんが
、
彼が探求するように、それらは非常に異なる
劇的
な質問です。
それが抑圧され
ていて、それらの質問がたくさん
あっ
ても大丈夫です。 あなたと
あなたはその質問に対する答えを見つけることができません
が、おそらくクリエイティブである可能性が高いということが常に返ってきます。この質問に答え
たい場合は、何が起こるかを探る
必要
があります たとえ
あなたがそれを知っていると思っていても答えに到達しますが、その
劇的な質問を探求することは私
がバルトスから教えられたもので
あり、私はその学習のまとも
な人になったと思います。 この世界はいはい
そしてもしあなたがそれがどのような
ものか例えば私にとって重要なことの1つは、
私が
父親になったときのような新しい劇的な
質問がポップアップしたようなものです.
私の子供に何かが起こり、それが起こった
場合、私はどうなるでしょうか.私は
もう
生きたいと思いますか.  Last of Us や God of War の
ようなこれらの質問を探求している現在のゲーム
この質問をしたクリエイターがこれについてメディアを作成したような
ものです
父親になることの意味 親になることの意味
喪失とは 子供は
あなたにできますか？  -世界と関わり、
それがあなたに起こった後、これらは
重要な質問であり、あなたは
それらの優れた
コンテンツを見ることができますはいアート私はアートアートが欲しいと
あなたは彼らが常にこれを念頭に置い
ていたこと、そしてそれらのすべての部分を持っていたことを見ることができると言いました
アート作品の方が強い
解決すべき問題があった場合 誰かがそれについて考えたからです
おそらく劇的な質問は
、何かが正しくないと感じた場合にそれを修正するのに役立ち
ます それは興味深い
です 私のお気に入りのアルバムの1つ
はそれです このアメリカのバンドは Merryweather Post Pavilion と呼んで
います ええと、彼らは American Animal
Collective だと思います。オープニングは実際に
は 2 番目の曲ですが、アルバム
の最初の適切な曲のように、前奏曲のようなものがあり
ます。私の女の子と私と呼ばれています。
私はこれを正しく理解していると思います
が、それはバンドのメンバーの1人が父親になって以来
、彼らが最初に書いた曲の1つであり、とても
強力な
曲であり、その意味で私は n は
あなたが言っていることと非常に関連しています。さまざまな芸術手段でそれを探求しようとすると
、劇的な質問がどのように変化するか、
それが
おそらく偉大な芸術を素晴らしいものにするものであり、
Edge Runners
があなたのためにクリックしたことを知っていると思います。 フィードバックを
いただいたことにとても感謝
して
いますが、クリックされなかった人がたくさんいて、
編集を行ってそれらすべての人々を読んだ
ことを知っています。 短く
て、キャラクターともっと時間を過ごしたかったのですが、
なぜルーシー
がデビッドに何かを言わなかったのか理解
できませんでし
た. その権利について
はそうではありませんが、彼らが質問をクリックしなかったことは理解しています。おそらく、彼らはその
経験をしたことがないか、または質問
が彼らの心にあるものに関連していなかったからです。
または彼らがしたい
探求する はい とてもそうです とてもとても
真実です
はい 私も
それ
についてはまだ話していません
前に話しました 私は
今この新しいプロジェクトに取り組んでいますが、私は
得るつもりはありません 今はあまりにも多くの詳細に陥っています
が、これは
私が苦労してきたことです.
彼から学んだことは 2 つあると
おっしゃっていたと思います.
ある意味での想像力
テクニカル ライティングのスキル
が驚くべき
ものでなくても、素晴らしい会話を書かなくてもストーリーを語らなければならない
方法があります。たとえば、それを見つける方法はありますが、
o あなたの想像力を解決するのに問題があり
ます 私は私のメール
が私の Twitter で公開された直後のように多くのこと
を受け取り
ます アイデア
と私はあなたが知っているようにしようとしています
そんなに時間がありませんが、
それらのメールに返信しようとしています.
ほとんどの場合、私はこのアイデアを持っています. アイデア
自体はそれほど
重要ではありません. そのアイデア
を実現できますか? このようなフェーズを押し進めることができます
か? これは興味深い話になると思います.
おそらく劇的な
質問はすでに私にあるかもしれ
ませんが、次に何が起こるか.
私が交流する多くの人にとって、私
はこのアイデアを持っているようで、そのアイデアを採用し
て私のために作ってくれますが、それはうまくいかないよう
です。何か
を作りたい場合は、人々と実際の仕事をしなければなりません。
他にもたくさん質問があります
このアイデアは、私が脚本家
になるべきか、アーティストになるべきか
、これは、
1つのレーンを選択するようなものです。ええ、おそらくそうです。そして
、最初は
誰もが何かを始めるの
はかなり下手で、絶対
に 彼ら
は、最も明らかなことの1つのようにそれにとどまれば良くなります.それは
実際に私に非常に興味深いものを与えてくれた別の同僚
です.だから私はいつもイラストレーター
のような手作業のスキルを持っている人をうらやましく思っています.
アーティストで、私はいつもとても嫉妬して
いました。なぜなら、私はそれがめちゃくちゃ
で、友達と酔っ払ったと言ったのです。
彼は世界で最も偉大なコンセプト アーティストの 1 人であり、
実際には世界のトップ 100 の
CD プロジェクトです。
私は彼に言った、あなたはとても才能があるように見える
私はとても嫉妬している 彼は彼が
言ったように私は誓うことができるといいのですが、彼
は言った 私は才能がありません.
yの場合は仕事を入れます
あなたはおそらく同じ場所にいない仕事をしますが
、私はすべてに関して
業界で才能のある個人として働いているでしょ
う。  YouTube を始めた
ばかり
の
頃、YouTube の友人の 1 人が私に
言ったことの 1 つです。 自分の能力に自信
がある 成功するかどうかではなく、いつ成功する
かが重要であり、私
はそれを強く信じており、それは
YouTube での最初の 2 年間で維持しようとした一種の考え方でしたが、
ええ、私は間違いなく同意します その
感情
はあなたの新しい努力について話しても大丈夫ですか
私は何かに取り組んでいると言うことができますが、私が取り組んでいるもの
ではありません 必ずしも仕事自体ではないという意味で言い換える必要があるかもしれません
しかし、あなたは CD project red で素晴らしい仕事をし
てくれました 今後やり
たいことを辞めるというあなたの決定について話してもらえますか
？ まず第一に、それ
は私だけではなく、
何百人もの人々がそれをやった
ので、プロジェクトで私と同じくらい多くの睡眠を
失ったことをあなたが知っている人々がいたように重要
です。 この無料の
レーンがあったので、私はうまくやる方法を知っています
.1つは、ライセンス契約を行う方法を知っている単なるビジネスマンであり
、ピアノを構築する方法などすべて
を知っています.もう1つは、
タレントビルディングチームと戦うプロデューサー能力です
3つ目は、
アイデアを
持っていて、それらを実現する方法を知っているクリエイティブ
であることです
少しビジネスの知識が
あり
、以前の仕事で非常に小さなレベルでプロデューサーの仕事をした
ことがありますが、私は私が私だと
感じています。  '私は物事の創造的な
側面にもっと取り組んでいますが、あなたにとって
は、3 つすべてのバランスが取れているように感じますか?
私
は順番に、あなたが最も
情熱を注いで
いるものがあると思います。 クリエイティブであることを追求したいのです
が、私の
最も経験が多いのはプロデューサー、
ビジネスパーソン
だと思います。業界で 10 年間、クリエイティブと仕事をし
、クリエイティブチームの一員として働いてきました
が、
私はそのようなことをリードしています。
アニメが実際に
始まる前は 2 年間
プリプロダクションを試みていたので、時間は短縮されました。私は
まだそれを担当してい
ました。
生産開始
はますます多くなり、私は
私はますます関与し、プロジェクト全体に対する所有権が現実になったので、一種の所有権を感じました。それは、いくつかの書類に署名しただけでなく、今では
何かですが、本当に何か
になり、現実になり始めたので
、私のミックス 能力 私
はそれらすべてに少し傾倒したいので
、それらは私をより良いクリエイターにすると思うので、それ
が理にかなっているなら、そう
です ご存知の制作の観点から、
私はもはや夢ではありません もはや夢想家ではありませんでし
た ああ、
この素晴らしいアイデアを思いついたので
、それを世に送り出し、これで
終わりです。チームを見つけなければなりません。締め切り
があり、お金があり、実際にそれを機能させる方法を見つけなければなりません。
あなたが夢を持っているだけでなく、
それは魔法のように
絶対に現れます。たとえば、私がバットマンの最も素晴らしいスクリプトを持っているかどうか
を知っているので、人々を説得してそのことを許可することを追求するビジネスの洞察力が必要です。
コミックボー わかり
ました。IP の所有者のところに行って、
この素晴らしいアイデアがあることを伝えなければなりません。
ある方法でそれを売り込む必要がありますが、彼らは
耳を傾けてくれるでしょう。彼らは
、私がこれは素晴らしいが、私のアイデアは正しいというメールを大量に受け取っているに違いありません。
もちろん、私がすでに確立されているように、悪評は役立ちます。
はい、一部の人々
は耳を傾けますが、同時に一部の人々は耳を傾け
ません。
私は自分のチームを編成しようとしていると感じて
おり、私たちはそれについて話しました。
それは仕事だけではありません。大丈夫です。
これは私が次にやりたい他のことを高める
か、これはとても大きなものでした。
IP のファン
他の状況に関係なく、一緒に仕事をしたい
彼らを見つけようとして
いる
その意味で、それはいつも私に喜びをもたらすものですが、探求したい
劇的な質問が少なくとも 2 つあると思います
将来は
大丈夫、私は彼らと一緒に何かをしたいのです
が、それはクリエイティブ側にあります
しかし、プロデューサー側
では、これらの質問を持っている人をサポートしたいのですが、
おそらく彼らはそれを行う方法がわからないかもしれませんが
、質問はクールであり
、それに対する答えも知りたいです.
ええ、とても興味深い
ですね。あなたは非常にユニークな状況にいると思います。
あなたはこれら 3 つのスキルをすべて備えているため、仮説的な状況
を知っていて
も、これらのスキルのいずれか
で客観的に優れている人が
いるということです。あなたが持っているからです。
たとえ
彼らがこの信じられないアイデアを持っていたとしても、あなた
も
持っている3つすべてでの経験。
このため、市場に出る
つもり
です。その意味で、私は
あなたが次に出すものに本当に
興奮して
います。  oで考慮される
素晴らしいものを作るために
、そして自分の強みに傾倒しようとしていると思います
ええ、日本は私の専門分野であり
、そのエッジのために、ランナーズは
実写テレビ番組ではありません アニメ
です 私がなるまでバケツリストがあったことをあなたは知りませ
ん 35
グローバルな世界で働いていることを知ってもらいたい 成功した
ビデオゲーム カードゲーム
を作りたい ボードゲームを作り
たい 自分のマンガを作りたい アニメを作りたい やりたいこと
リストがいっぱい
私は何も持っていないことをすべてやりましたが、それは
とてもばかげたことでした。ポーランドの小さな村に住んでいた男がそれらのことをしたいと思っているようなものです。その意味ではばかげていますが
、最初は別の場所で始まり
、 それから私は境界線を押し広げる方法を見つけようとしました。
私はまだ作家ではないかもしれませんが、
他の誰かと一緒に何かを書かせてください。彼ら
から学ぶことができるように、作家の近くにい
させてください。試してみてください。 今
持っているスキルを使って、できる限り役に立ちたい
新しいスキルを身につけて、自分ができることをさらに上手にできるように
します。皆さんとの会話からも、若い人たちはああ、ああ、クリエイターを介し
てすぐに作りたいと思っていることを知っています。
自分のショーを作る
のはそうではないようです。 何かへの現実的な道、
またはあなたが28歳のチェーンソーマンの作者ではない場合、これらはこれらで
あり、彼
はすでにそのような素晴らしい作品を書いてい
ます.
彼は確かに働き者で
もあると思うので、あなたに彼を天才に還元することは知りたくないのです
が、彼は世界の
他の誰も持っていないと思うミックスを
持っていますが、私は私が試したことでした.
私の有用性を私がする
ことすべてに活用し、そのため、私の創造的なものがどれも良くない場合でも、私はまだという意味で
、少しのセーフティネットを維持しながら、
私が情熱を注いでいると感じた方向に向かって一歩を踏み出し
ます
この時点から、私はすでにこれを行っており、私
も ビジネス
パーソンは永遠に必要とされると思う
ので、私ができる安全なことだと思います
が、私はテーブルに持ち込むこともあり
、ある意味ではもはやそうではありません。
ああ、
これはアイデアだと言いますが、私はああ、これがアイデアだと言います。これが私
たちがこのアイデアを実行する方法です。
はい、絶対にそうです。これは、
新しいクレイジーなプロジェクトに自信をもたらすのに大いに役立ち
ます。
これが現実になることはありませんでした。
これが可能性があるかどうかを探ってみましょう。
しかし、その
ため、今はプロデューサーの
帽子をかぶり、ビジネスの帽子をかぶり
、クリエイターの帽子を持ってきました。ええと、それらを変更できます
帽子、部屋での私の有用性
は高いので、そう
です、あなたが売り込んでいるCDプロジェクトレッドであなたが持っていたに違いない会話のいくつかのために、私は壁に
ハエになりたいと思っていました。
これから作ることができるかもしれません ボードゲーム
からアニメを作ることができるかもしれません。
もちろん
、ビジネスの
観点に戻ると、数字で現実的になる必要があります。ええええ、
それは素晴らしいアイデアですが、
私たちが「
必要な賃金を支払うことができませんが
、私が
言いたいのは、ショーを見てくれたことにとても感謝しているということです。
私がネオジェニズムで描写したあなたが行く感覚は
、私が世界でたった一人の誰かに何か新しいものを与えるその人になれたら、私は
これまでで最も幸せになるだろうと
思うからです。 前に車の中で交わした会話の一部をシェアしても構いません.
ええと、私は人生で3回、私の人生の流れを変え
た特定の芸術作品にとても感動したという経験をしまし
た. 私が13歳の
ときにこの日本のパンクバンドを見つけたのが最初です
日本語を勉強するきっかけになったの
は 2 つ目は、最初
にしなりんご東京事変の
コンサートに行ったときです。
3 つ目は
Edge Runners を見た後です 皆さん
は私を Dogan として知って
います もちろん日本語関連の
言語を扱う YouTuber
ですが、この番組を見て以来、
この別のプロジェクトを同時に追求しようと決心しました 将来
皆さんと共有することを楽しみにし
ているので、ショーを十分に賞賛することはできません。
もう1つ
明確にしたいのは、
あなたが言及したことの1つは
、 それ
は必ずしもエッジランナーにあまり共鳴しません
でした 聴衆は
おそらく
、
自分自身を作家だと考えている人として、または
私がいつも
映画やアニで見ているものは何でも、劇的な質問に関連付けることができる立場になかったかもしれません. 私や
非常に分析的な目を持つあらゆる種類の物語で、
これについても少し話しましたが、
基本的にすべてを見ているときは、非常に批判的になるようにしています。
Edge Runners について私を驚かせたのは、通常
50 の異なるものがある
ためです。どのコンテンツについても、少し気分が悪いと思います。これの
1 つの例のように、あなたは 1 秒前にチェーンソーの男を育てました。
「今もそれを見てい
ますが、それは全世界が
そうです。全世界は
、その最初のエピソードで書き留めた多くのことの中で、私にとって少し気分
が
悪いと感じたものの1つです。ええと、デンジは悪魔と戦っています.
最初のエピソードと悪魔が持っているセリフの 1 つは、
私があなたを少しずつスライスしたのに、なぜあなたはまだ生きているの
かということ
です。 それは少しbを感じました
私たちが持っていることの1つは、
その質問をまったく提起する必要
があるということです。これは、ひどくではなく冗長である可能性があることですが、主な
ことは、悪魔に一種の言葉を使用させること
です。
ええと、スラングのように、それは悪魔が
私にとって少し安っぽいように感じます
私がその行を覚えているとき、私
はそれがそうで
あり、作者の意図がわからないということでした
もちろんもちろん私にとってはそれは実際に人間化されているようでした
悪魔は
人間と同じくらいめちゃくちゃだからそのように話すという意味での悪魔であり、それが
なければ私は
悪魔をただの怪物と考えるでしょうが
、そのラインが到着したら私は大丈夫ですので
、彼らはこの複雑さを持っています
それ自体は人間のためだけなので、
彼らは頭が
悪いかもしれませんし、頭が良いかもしれませんが、愕然とするかもしれません。
和解する デンジが悪魔を殺した後
、別のキャラクターの
ハヤカラがデンジと話して
いる第 2 話の終わりに向かって少しラインがあると思います。 あなたの
力を使って彼を殺すと、彼女は私
が彼を不必要に苦しめたくなかったと言い
、ハヤカワが
戻ってきて、彼は
敵に同情しないで
ください、あなたは悪魔と友達になりたいですか
、そしてこの信じられないほどのセリフを言います. デンジ
はその後、悪魔
が私と友達になりたいならそれでいいと言います。私には友達が
いない
ので、それはデンジについて多くを教えてくれ
ますが、悪魔の複雑さについても教えてくれ
ます。 ええ、
私はこれとそれ
が作家としての彼の才能だと思うので、ええええ、私はマンガ全体を正しく読んでいるので
、あなたがしなければならないと言っているシリーズのために、彼はすでに何かを将来的に設定しているという意味で
今
は漫画版チェーンソーマン再臨みたいなボリューム
だけどネタバレなしで全部読み終わった
後はすごい
ドラマチックな質問だ
な ひどい人​​は善人になれるの？
そのセットアップのおかげで、そのセットアップの深化のおかげで
、作家としての私と同じように、その
ような長期にわたる
ものを持ち、それらすべてのちょっとした
ことを非常に綿密に計画しているという意味で、まだできない驚くべきことです。
それは起こることですが
、私の経験から、そこには直感があった可能性が最も高いですが、
完全に計画さ
れて
いなかっ
た可能性があります。 あなたは
それを書き留めます、そしてそれ
は書き留められるものになりますあなたはそれを
あなたの脳に持っていて、あなたはすでに
そこに思考プロセスを持っています。
人生で他に
起こっていることがあるなら、取りつかれて
いるかもしれませんし
、それは可能かもしれませ
んが、そうでない場合は、それらの種を植えて本当に成長するのは何よりも直感かもしれません。なぜなら
ジョージ・R・マーティンを見れば たとえば、彼
はそれがどこで終わるかを知っているが、
彼がそんなに長くかかる理由は、彼がそれが何であるかを知っている
からです。
はいはい、しかし
彼が書いたものはまだ公開されていなかったかもしれ
ませんが、彼はそれを書き直すことができるので
、彼は書いている間は考えていなかった新しいアイデアを書いているので、彼はすでに書いたものを常に書き直しています。
絶対
にそれは非常に長いメディアのような一種の難問です
ええ
ええ絶対にまた戻って
きます私はチェーンソーマンを読んだこと
がないので、それがどうなるかわかり
ませんあなたが話しているかどうかわかりません の 主人公
であろうとなかろうと、スポイラーの
領域
には入りませんが、私にとってそれについて非常に
際立っている
ことの1つは、これらの少年ヒーローのほとんどが
彼らは悲惨な状況から来て
おり、それにもかかわらず強いキャラクターを持ってい
ます。
ええと、ええと、あなたが言うことのないところまでです。財団
ええええ、彼らには道徳
がありますが
、ゲンジがこれと戦っているチェーンソーマンには素晴らしいシーンがあります。 この種の
コウモリの悪魔は、エピソード 3 3 エピソード 3 で思います。
車の中に民間人がいて
、戦いの邪魔をしていて、彼は
それを横に投げるのが好きです。ええ、最初の
セットアップはさらに優れてい
ます。 車
の中に人間がいるから車を使うつもりはないんだけど、彼女が言うには
、その
設定はとても興味深い。
強い
モラル いくつかの
根底にある強いモラルが
あるということですが、少なくともその前提は、彼が
この惨めな設定から来
て、私たちが慣れていない非定型のモラルを持っているということですが、それに
もかかわらず、彼の闘争を考えると、彼
は 一貫して
書かれたキャラクターであり、その
一貫性のために、
観客が彼に完全に共感することは許容され
ます.今あなたが言ったことをノートのように正確に書き留め
て、今シリーズを進めてい
ますが、話すことができるのは魅力的です.
あなたは私がして
いることとは
根本的に異なるバックグラウンドから来ており、
このビデオを録画する前に私たちが言ったもう1つのことは、
私がこのYouTubeの世界に住んでいるということ
です. あなたが言った
ように、あなたは完全に創造的な自由を持っているので、あなたはあなたが
やりたいことをある程度選択することができ
ます。
ある意味でそれをナビゲートする必要がありますが、
ええと、私は常により優れたアートを
作成することにはるかに興味を持っていまし
た。その意味で、
これを持っていることは素晴らしいことです
とても素晴らしいものを作った方とお話する機会
があるので、それで締めくくるのが良いかもしれませ
ん。皆さんが
私たちの会話からいくつかのことを
学べたことを願っています。エッジ ランナーを見たことがない場合や、ラファエルから学ぶ
場合
ウィッチャーローニン
は彼の最初の主要なコンメジャーなクリエイティブな
エンデバー
でした。大学は常にモンスターだったので、私のお気に入りのアニメのために両方をもう一度チェックすることを強く
お勧めします。 あなたはそれを知っているかどうかはわかり
ませんが、もちろんDr Tenma
は私のお気に入りのアニメでしたが、モンスターを上回りました.
特にアニメは
、あなたが
さまざまなインタビューでそれを行ったからです。
みんなにチェックすることをお勧めしますが、その
前に、アニメを見に行くことをお勧めします。
それは傑作です。それは
ランドマークであり、あなたが何をするかを見るのが待ちきれ
ません 次は、
お時間をいただきありがとうございました ありがとうございました
お話
できて楽しかったです